u.s defense secretary lloyd austin will
host the gathering of top military
leaders from about 40 countries at the
u.s air base in ramstein germany in the
coming hours they expected to focus on
how to best assist the ukrainian
military and supply weaponry to counter
the russian invasion this after a day of
heavy bombardment in the east and
northeast regions of the country
this man is being evacuated from his
home in her keys
trapped in his flat it is a miracle he
survived
[Music]
they've been bombarding us all day and
all night
in the beginning it was quieter at night
the bombing only happened during the day
but later they began bombing at night
too
bombs
has endured a barrage of russian attacks
constant shelling has reduced much of
the city to ashes
now some 50 residents have been
evacuated from one frontline
neighborhood
they have been taken to shelters
where they hope to be safe
about 400 kilometers south safety is
still a distant dream
russian forces continue to pummel the
azov style steel factory the last pocket
of resistance in mario paul
the port city has been under siege for
weeks now
most of it has been wiped out by russian
bombardment
the dire fate of mariopol has been a
warning to other ukrainian cities
and to protect them ukraine's president
vladimir zelinsky has asked allies for
more support
everyone in the world even those who
openly did not support us now agrees
that the fate of europe the fate of
global security and the fate of the
democratic system is being decided in
ukraine
this is why representatives from across
the world will be meeting here at
ramstein air base in germany
u.s defense secretary lloyd austin is
set to host talks that will focus on
arming ukraine
rebecca reiters is our correspondent in
the ukrainian capital kiev joining us
from there what is the government in
kiev expecting from that war conference
of 40 nations in ramstein today
well president zielinski and the
ukrainians have been very clear in their
messaging from the very beginning of
this conflict what they want
is simply weapons weapons support so
they can push back the russians in their
territory but today's meeting at
ramstein is less about what ukraine want
and what president zielinski wants and
more about the u.s looking to its allies
in nato for support u.s has been the
biggest supporter of ukraine in this
conflict so far secretary
anthony blinken and lloyd austin were
just here at the weekend and they came
with more
more offers of support in the way of
weapons and money and now they're going
to their allies to ask for uh you know
support in that there has been a lot of
criticism from some of the nato allies
germany in particular that they haven't
been doing enough neither before the
conflict started or since it began uh we
have heard word this morning though
there's a report in the sudochi zaitong
german newspaper that the defense
minister the german defense minister is
set to announce the deployment or the
the go ahead for some german tanks to be
brought to ukraine which has been long
debated in germany now so that will
definitely be met uh positively by the
americans but today's meeting really
just an attempt to get everybody singing
from the same songbook
now the un secretary general is also
engaging in shuttle diplomacy he's
expected in moscow today for talks with
vladimir putin does the government in
kiev hold any hope that he can achieve
anything
i i don't think so no gerhard i mean i
think uh any hope of a peace deal by you
that you're brokered by antonio guterres
today or this week is is really unlikely
i don't think anybody's holding hope out
for that uh something that they may be
that maybe even more realistic goal if
you will that is being being talked
about here is of course a much needed
humanitarian corridor out of that
besieged city of mariupol where there
are still some 2000 ukrainian soldiers
and some civilians really are believed
to be uh trapped underneath that as of
steel plant and president zielinski has
long been calling for their evacuation
he's also said that if russia doesn't
allow them to be evacuated and if they
go ahead and bombard that to the point
where those soldiers are killed that
that will basically mean the end of
peace negotiation so really unlikely
that uh any anything in terms of the
peace deal will come out of these talks
by the u.n secretary general this week
uh
you know i i think uh key of not holding
out too much hope for that gerhard
rebecca is there reporting from keefe
thank you rebecca